je voulais pas là
à l'oubli
[Musique]
alors on en est au niveau du goulot
prêter réunion de suite
ok très bien on a une nouvelle commande
de jeu le coup mais depuis on dispose
5000 euros carole je dirais plutôt 93
minutes après un but de hockey notre
studio canadien en année on wii a alors
attendez là les scénaristes ont commencé
à travailler dessus
ils nous ont envoyé toutes sortes de
dessin et d'histoire regarder le
scénario par commun sinon privé de
bolbec mais enfin mdc des besoins et
cette fois ci je peux pas de canadiens
je veux que le jeu soit impeccable sinon
les actionnaires et boncourt année et
sinon il s'appelle comment le jeu j'ai
une idée émane du bonheur jeux
playstation 2 sorti en 2006 vous c'est
on critique beaucoup les équipes de
développement dans cette émission mais
je suis sûr qu'ils font tout leur
possible pour nous offrir le meilleur
produit
arrêté par les ponts le budget fond à
vue d'oeil le jeu commence par un bref
morceau d'histoire où on apprend que
vous êtes james farrington votre fils a
été tué alors qu'il était bébé votre
femme violée avant d'être assassiné puis
elle même transformé en vampire vous
accordez donc le mari parti pour
assassiner sa femme celle qui la
dernière chose qu'il concert avoir des
suicides
vous lisez bien les avances je crois que
l'un des scénaristes va pas très bien
dans sa vie personnelle en se marrant
donc vous êtes un chasseur de vampires
d'après le jeu cela fait des dizaines
d'années que vous chassez votre femme et
vous venez finalement de la retrouver
mais tout au long du jeu on comprend
vite pourquoi vous avez vidé dizaine
d'années elle a retrouvé la raison c'est
que vous tuez la faire
aussitôt le jeu commence et vous faites
du bruit comme un débile qui lui permet
d'échapper le héros en bois quoi je fais
des trains trouvée match bref revenons
en arrière donc votre femme arrive a
visiblement et la narration un autre
personnage nous explique donc jack
l'éventreur et bien ce serait peut-être
en fait elle si je vous jure à écouter
[Musique]
vous entendez sache elle chez la marche
des professionnels le jeu est donc un
fps et nous avons comme arme un petit
couteau et un air très sérieux je vous
jure que c'est pas être vraies armes
c'est pas possible c'est un erp écouter
y est je me sens tellement puissant et
puis merde le viseur et même pas en face
de la croix en plus vous avez 15 heures
vous même
donc on suit notre femme dans les rues
de londres ont modélisé totalement de
penoy c'est pas d'open world certes mais
au moins comme c'est un jeu récent on
n'aura pas les inévitables niveau dans
les égouts le premier passage et donc
dans les égoûts et on suit donc d'autres
femmes à travers les égouts en
affrontant des goulets on peut au moins
reconnaître qu'il y ait localisation des
dégâts quand vous en tirez dans la jambe
il tombe quand vous leur tirer dans la
tête et
quoi quand vous leur tirer dans la tête
elle explosé dans 70% des cas ils
meurent mais ça arrive une fois sur
trois ou quatre qu'il continue à marcher
sans aucun problème
et attendez je sais ce que ça va être
l'excusé ça va être en baisse à va se
déroule ce des êtres surnaturels mais
finalement quand on y pense
ils sont pas déjà un peu mort et puis on
pense pas bref heureusement c'est pas
très dur de trouver la sortie il suffit
de suivre les lumières et voilà donc au
bout d'un moment on a
ok bonjour série de bien c'est ça tu me
trompes a qu'une poule et en plus il bat
p des trucs à 3 alors ok alors je sais
pas trop ce qui s'est passé à vrai dire
je pense que le script qui déclenche la
fuite de votre femme doit être buggé
parce que j'ai recommencé plusieurs
partis et à chaque fois elle restée
plantée là pendant plusieurs minutes à
se faire taper par des gaules qui font
des bruits de rideau 0
f après ce petit temps mort l'histoire
reprend et on arrive donc à la surface
ou en poursuivant notre femme ont fini
par tomber sur d'autres vampires qui
contrairement aux rouleaux vont demander
une toute nouvelle stratégie pour les
battre on fait léviter on voit donc
d'autres femmes s'échapper
mon dieu mais elle va si vite samedi
veuve d'un immeuble moi jamais la
rattraper à la prochaine rue tourner à
droite
après cette folle poursuite la voilà qui
tourne dans une ruelle et wau aux
[ __ ] de hockey tarder c'est pas censé
être le boss final du jeu ou un truc
comme ça maintenant vampire tu ne me
susurre a pas mieux ok tant des quads
donc quoi j'ai vu j'ai fini j'ai fini le
jeu ça y est j'ai gagné sept écrans de
faible niveau qui est l'un des plus
tristes que j'ai pu voir de mal je
connais pas je gagnais là c'était
dormition avec l'image de type effondré
sous la pluie comme un sdf
waouh c'est donc ça le sentiment
réussite bref le niveau de commenceront
suis encore notre femme qui s'échappe
par un bateau notre personnage qui l'a
poursuivie jusqu'aux doc est vide et à
douchapt d'abord et c'est également
l'occasion de croiser un nouveau méchant
avec des animations d'un niveau jamais
atteint attention
[Musique]
et
dans ce niveau nous avons donc une
nouvelle arme un pistolet avec son super
zoom attention 3 2 1 et le but ici va
être de s'introduire dans cet entrepôt
pour atteindre ce bateau ici dans cet
entrepôt là pour atteindre ce bateau ici
est logique
ici on doit passer sans se faire repérer
et aider que vampire vous voit vous avez
cet écran de game over nul mais le souci
c'est que du coup comme cet écran
appareils de suite impossible de savoir
quelle vampires vous à vue et comme vous
peut savoir ça bah du coup impossible de
s'améliorer genre quoi qui m'a vu l'a
dit quoi à la caisse
évidemment on peut fabriquer les garde
pour aller direct sur le bateau peut pas
péter les lumières fait de toute façon
c'est pas grave parce que c'est de la
merde je suis debout en pleine lumière
sur une plate forme est bonne et tout ça
ouvre les yeux fume pas je dis moi c'est
le random du pipe jean roy n'a pas vu
lui sérieusement et il a eu besoin six
tailles qui vit depuis plus personne
les personnes autour hier de la
cohérence bordel ya les boîtiers un
ennemi qui vont à travers les murs et
l'autre qui est complètement sourd et
aveugle
2010 [ __ ] c'était un an avant le
premier modern warfare c'était un an
après spinter cell 3 ça c'est maintenant
avant moi ça donne quoi ce niveau
d'infiltration
c'est de la merde horrible démissionne
on me censure aussi mal puis au moins on
n'est pas en retard et on allait au
niveau budget écoutez je pense comme à
bientôt être à court il faudra envisager
des coupes
le troisième niveau maintenant vous êtes
enfermé dans un monastère et est ce que
c'est moi vraiment où est ce que ça
devient de pire en pire
garetta le flec fait rien et les
animations des ennemis c'est la
catastrophe
bonjour bonjour des meneurs [ __ ] je
vais toutes les balles dedans c'est quoi
ce pistolet à blanc sérieusement est-ce
que je peux pas les tuer parce que c'est
des vampires ou est-ce que je peux pas
aller tuer parce que le jeu il est
complètement buggé les ennemis n'ont
aucune animation quand ils prennent des
coups il n'y a même pas une pauvre
traces de sang il ya juste ça bruits de
cailloux jetés dans un lac ou encore en
les jantes et sur aube
bien sûr que non et c'est quoi ces
décors de merde de playstation eux et
cette ambiance de merde qui fait pas
peur
art
[Musique]
pour faire ce songe à savoir à quel jeu
punition il est donc temps de découvrir
les combats au couteau les assurés
normal un combat au couteau dans ce jeu
mais juin chasseur de vampires pourquoi
est ce que je me bats avec le truc qui
sert à tartiner du beurre bonjour j'ai
envie de vous dire que ce couteau c'est
le chanteur mais le cancer au moins et
tuent des gens et puis ça fait cinq ou
plus avec [ __ ] c'est une forme d'art
de rater autant de trucs c'est possible
de faire pire encore
et ben alors vous savez entendu le
monsieur la malaisie au bout d'un moment
vous allez tomber sur ces petits ennemis
des espèces de lutins et [ __ ] mais n'y
sont trop bas pour votre viseur vous
pouvez pas descendre plus bas
[Musique]
ok bon alors finalement vous escaladez
donc la tour à la recherche du méchant
qui s'était installé en haut de la tour
le méchant sans fuite devant vous et
donc qu'on le poursuivre
et tant que j'y suis donnez moi une
seule raison logique d'installer votre
bureau pour travailler
non bref vous suivez le méchant et
s'ensuit un combat ultra nul à base de
moi qui m'en fille pendant 10 minutes
parce que côté pouls de la vie pour dell
il n'y a aucun moyen de régénérer de la
vie dans ce [ __ ] de jeu même au bout
de plusieurs minutes d'acharnement j'ai
réussi enfin à battre l'ennemi voilà
alliés j'ai gagné maintenant
chaque fin de niveau le conflit loval
complique l'ovale compliquer le niveau
suivant se passe dans un asile à londres
après avoir trébuché jobs se réalise que
les demis qui poursuit depuis des
centaines d'années celui qui avait
poussé sa femme a tué son fils avant de
la transformer en vampire avait en tête
un frère jumeau et ne s'en était jamais
rendu compte
le but des deux frères jean pierre et en
d'invoquer un démon il décide que le
plan le plus simple pour se débarrasser
de nous et de nous mettre dans une
caisse sur bateau à direction de londres
pour nous envoyer dans un asile de fous
habité par le loup garou et quantum qui
a bien collectionner les montres afin
d'y être mangés par d'autres femmes
alors ce niveau particulièrement
stressant consiste à essayer de tuer
votre femme tout en évitant la menace du
loup garou alors je vous préviens le
loup garou bouge très vite attention aux
clercs job je crois qu'il est là juste
derrière derrière ce point dur
attention
[Musique]
et si le coeur vous attrape un
évidemment vous vous doutez de ce qui
arrive
il vous faut
[Musique]
et comme je disais un pendant ce niveau
vous allez également rencontré un
fantôme qui apparemment a l'air super
important à l'histoire il t'en vas faire
plein de trucs d'abord cherché son corps
c'est une montre chercher une clé avant
de trouver de l'argent pour fabriquer
des balles en argent pour tuer de
nougaro afin de libérer l'âme des
fantômes ce qui te donne des munitions
afin de tuer ta femme pour finir le
niveau là [ __ ] ça m'a pris trois mois
ces maquettes est parfaite voilà alors
donc vous pouvez faire tout ça ou alors
en sortant de votre cellule vous
ramasser une lampe à uv par terre et
voulu balancer sur la gueule
bref une fois échappé de l'asile vous
partez à la recherche de la carte pour
trouver l'île des vampires invocateurs
de démons mais c'est bizarre ce niveau
ressemble un peu aux docks du niveau 2
si ça doit être un genre de coïncidence
on y affrontent donc des mercenaires
nougaro mortels et de dangereux vampire
podium et poussettes boyelles bougeotte
peau et finalement en haut du niveau
vous trouvez la carte qui vous amène
vers le niveau suivant
c'est cette carte là je dois trouver une
île qui s'appelle europe après avoir
recyclé la carte des docks du deuxième
niveau le jeu dans un souci d'écologie
s'est dit qu'il allait recyclé également
la carte du troisième niveau des modes
suscitant des enseignants
c'est donc reparti pour exactement la
même carte qu'au niveau 3 le monastère
mais cela dit les développeurs ont quand
même rajouter en plus un brouillard de
guerre parce que c'est vrai que les dix
niveaux précédents étaient beaucoup trop
lumineux à la stratégie classique du jeu
baisse la luminosité parce que quand on
n'y voit rien c'est pas moche
bref comme je disais donc de revoilà sur
l'île du monastère vous pensez qu'il a
montré sa carte au capitaine du navire
qui l'a mené ici vous emmenez moi là
alors je vais même pas vous parler du
niveau en fait il n'y a plus rien y'a
plus de quêtes ya plus de pnjs juste des
zombies qui sortent au hasard et qu'on
retire et là il y avait plus de budget a
clairement défini et donc on arrive
enfin au regard des niveaux le boss
final
ah merde mon voisin utilise la perceuse
c'est le bruit du démon ils ont dit se
son
pour faire le bruit de démons c'était
quoi ces travaux qu'ils ont filmée au
loin
ce mec qui parle au ralenti attendait
peut-être que c'est un message des
développeurs peut-être que si j'accélère
leçon je comprendrais enfin le sens
caché de ce jeu peut-être que c'est plus
profond qu'il n'y paraît
abréger le dernier combat est aussi
agréable comme toucher rectal c'est par
un boxeur on affronte donc un gros des
mots complètement pato est ridicule ben
alors certes il a la capacité de devenir
invisible mais ça va c'est pas un gros
problème je sais que tu es là le
blizzard de mon arme allait te vois
et en fait à vrai dire ce niveau serait
super facile si avait pas de nouveau ces
[ __ ] de petite merde [ __ ] la fin du
jeu a intérêt à être exceptionnel
[Musique]
un métro man une caméra qui zoome sur un
livre du texte du vote deux textes tout
se finit là dessus rien d'autre rentrer
chez vous allez je fais jamais mais en
l'honneur des créateurs quand même je
vais laisser un petit peu de génériques
chen xin shi incroyable de voir
qu'encore à l'époque de la playstation 2
on a des jeux de ce niveau un trou noir
ça suce - du que que ce jeu ce jeu il
est il et ce n'est pas fini et c'est
fini bravo tout le monde on a travaillé
très dur pour en arriver là
enfin surtout vous et je veux juste
partir avec l'argent
d'accord avec toi que chef de projet
dans la vie bon ça va
et puis au moins la boîte ferme bien va
très bien maintenant le service
marketing plan de la suite
je tiens à remercier aussi nos studios
l'étranger surtout les scénaristes qui
ont fait un excellent travail et
derniers mois fort il faut les siestes
et notre studio japonais sous pétain qui
fait un excellent travail de son design
levier courte mélange elle est éternelle
tous ces efforts bon vin payés à 45
euros le jeu on serait enfin je serai
vite aux niches
[Musique]
e
on
[Musique]